read em ours is bustling with activity
this lunchtime crowd includes students
artists and social activists example
from the black lives matter movement
exactly the target demographic for
Hillary Clinton voters right I not a big
fan of Hillary Clinton I did not have
high hopes for her in terms of really
moving of progressive radically Left
agenda at all I think that she would
have fended to corporate interests
instead of the interest in working-class
focus Ken Brown is one of the shops
owners devoted for Jill Stein the
candidate representing the Green Party
in comparison to previous elections
Clinton wasn't able to win over as many
african-american voters as President
Obama did some of them voted for Trump a
lot of people falsely I think believed
that Trump would be the more populist
person that Trump would have
working-class interested in hand I don't
think that's true but many people
believe that including some people of
color Baltimore is a city in Maryland
Marylanders are rich stay but it's tough
time for the african-american population
on average incomes a half of what they
are for white people and 24 percent of
the population lives in poverty there is
a lack of jobs that do not require a
college degree therein lies the tension
between black and white
in 2015 the city made headlines due to
the death of Freddie gray
he was 25 when he was arrested and died
while in police custody protests
followed for weeks to come
Clinton who did win Maryland's electoral
votes however the support from African
Americans seems to be wavering
one thing was a lot of people voted
independence a lot of people voted for
Bernie and when Bernie didn't make it
they kind of fell out and just felt like
their voices weren't being heard
it just wasn't important seemed like to
me like it is you know like it was for
the first black you know that was very
important for everybody because that was
like real history Hillary would have
been real history also but um it was
just more important for Obama for us
Clinton was not able to inspire African
Americans the way Barack Obama did the
result of this presidential election has
shuffled the deck thinks once taken for
granted our normal work African American
does not automatically Democrat